[Music]
all right
my name is teen Yun and I'm a product
manager on the cloud AI team and today
I'm here to talk about how you can
tackle some of your high value business
problems using Auto ml on one of the
most common types of data in the
enterprise structured data but before we
dig in I wanted to first make sure
everyone knows what I'm talking about
when I when I say a machine learning on
structured data right so these use cases
typically start with a table of input
kind of like this where each row is an
independent training example and usually
one of these columns is the target
column and the remaining columns are
input features and the goal is to create
a machine learning model to predict the
value of the target column accurately
using the available input feature values
for that row so for example here you may
have a visit Oh example you might have a
table of historic offers from an online
marketplace and you want to create a
model that takes the available data on
that offer to predict the price at which
that offer is sold so for example if you
want to provide pricing guidance to your
sellers and one common misconception I
wanted to point out is that people
sometimes think that you can only have
simple values like numbers and classes
inside a table but actually especially
with modern data warehouse systems like
bigquery
you can put a rich set of things in
there things like timestamps long pieces
of texts lists of features potentially
repeated nested fields and that would be
only getting started so according to the
McKay the McKinsey Global Institute data
in this basic form structured data is
likely to drive most of a i's impact
with time series being a close second
and this really comes as no surprise
because virtually every industry has
mission-critical use cases that can be
boiled down into this tabular form so
for example in retail predicting the
likelihood of stock outs of predicting
price elasticity so you can optimize
your product inventory in finance
predicting the risk of large claims or
defaults or predicting the likelihood
fraud in the next in this transaction in
order to manage your risk in marketing
predicting lifetime value like how much
they'll spend on your site in the next
three weeks predicting whether they'll
churn so that you can better understand
your customer the list goes on and these
are use cases that are so core to their
respective industries that even small
improvements in model call in model
quality can have significant significant
business implications but the challenge
is that especially as the number and
complexity of your input columns
increases you hit a combinatorial
explosion in things you need to worry
about so starting from the left and
going to the right on data preparation
for every one of your individual feature
columns you need to think about things
like missing values and outliers and so
forth and then under feature engineering
for each of those columns you need to
think of the right pre-processing to
prepare it for the following model that
you select in the architech architecture
selection step and there could be
multiple options per feature column and
then under architecture selection there
are dozens of models you could choose
from
including more that come out from the
research community basically on a
monthly basis and then for each of those
models you select you have to select the
right hyper parameters and there could
potentially be a dozen values to set and
then you have to think about tuning
think about ensemble if you're trying to
create an especially good model as well
as model evaluation and oh by the way if
you screw up in any one of these
individual steps frequently you have to
start over and this process of iteration
can go on for tens of times especially
if you have a hard a hard data set I
think we've data scientists in the room
have probably all experienced experience
that before so this entire process can
take months potentially dooming machine
learning projects all together as
executive sponsors lose interest so in
order to help you overcome these
challenges we decided to build Auto ml
tables a tool for enabling your entire
team whether you're a data scientist an
analyst or a developer to automatically
build and deploy state-of-the-art
machine learning models on structured
data and I'm excited to announce that
autumn
tables is entering into public beta as
of this morning thank you and the way
the product works is we provide a
graphical coalesce interval interface
for guiding users through the entire n10
machine learning lifecycle with
significant automation as well as
guardrails built in at each individual
step which I will show you shortly
inside a demo so we start with helping
you ingest your data and then easily
define your data schema and target
analyze your input features in a feature
statistics dashboard automatically train
your model including automated feature
engineering model selection and hyper
parameter tuning as well as evaluate
your model behavior before deploying
into production and then deploying in a
single click through this we can help
ensure that what used to take months of
time only takes weeks or even days
digging deeper into some of these
different steps so on that on the data
ingestion side we enable we seek to
handle data as found in the wild so we
provide automated feature engineering
for essentially the major data
primitives that you can find in bigquery
things like numbers time stamps classes
lists strings and nested fields we do
know there are more other data
primitives out there that we could cover
but this is this is our starting point
and we also worked hard to ensure that
we're resilient to and provide
guardrails 4 imbalance data missing
values highly correlated features high
cardinality features like if every row
had a different ID and outliers as well
after that we automatically search
through Google's entire model zoo to
find the best model for you including
linear logistic regression for the
smaller simpler data sets as well as
things like deep neural Nets ensembles
as well as well as architecture search
methods if you have a larger more
complicated data set and one of the
benefits of being at Google is we sit
next to some of the best research and
consumer product teams in the world so
we can basically watch whatever great
research results come out and take the
best and put it into automail tables for
you kind of cherry-picking the best for
you sometimes even before results are
published on them
in research papers so hot off the press
an example of this is our collaboration
with the Google brand team so they
delivered what they call Nero and tree
architecture search so essentially what
this is that is they took their
architecture search capability similar
to the one that they use for image
classification and translation problems
and they added tree based architectures
to the existing neural net architecture
search space and then also added
automated feature engineering so that it
can work for a wide variety of
structured data note that this isn't
published in research papers yet so I
can't give more details but expect more
to be announced soon and based on the
benchmarks we've done the results are
the results speak for themselves
so there are a large number of vendors
in this space and we chose to benchmark
against a subset of them with similar
functionality and we bench dart we and
we benchmarked on kaggle competitions
which I love as a benchmark because they
involve real data from real companies
that are putting tens to hundreds of
thousands of dollars of prize money on
the line to find a good solution and
they're willing to wait months to get a
good answer that's typically how long
these competitions take and thousands of
data scientists across the world compete
in them so these are if you do well on a
Kangol competition in terms of the
ranking you're pretty much guaranteed
that you're doing state-of-the-art work
on a problem that matters for the world
so that's why we love this class of
benchmarks and here you have on the
x-axis different data sets that we
different Kaggle challenges that we
benchmarked on and on the y-axis is the
percent ranking on the essentially the
final cago leaderboard
if we had actually participated so these
challenges had already ended by the time
we participated we were just
benchmarking on the final leaderboard
afterward after the fact and what you'll
see is that most of the time Automall
tables gets into the top 25% which tends
to be better than the existing vendors
we tested but caveats apply of course
for some of these data sets we were in
the middle of the pack and we'll be the
first to admit that we have a lot of
additional work to do and we're
constantly tuning and improving
systems but when it comes down to it in
general we do pretty well so benchmark
results are here and I wanted to dig
into one of these benchmarks to give you
a better sense of what it means to get
into the top 25% so here's an example
called the Macari price suggestion
challenge Macari is Japan's biggest
community powered shopping app and
marketplace and they created this
challenge for predicting the price of a
product offered on their marketplace so
that they could give pricing suggestions
to their sellers so this is a real
version of the example problem that I
brought up at the beginning of this talk
so some logistics this challenge went on
for about three months there was
$100,000 prize 2,000 data scientists
competed and actually the winning data
scientist made about 99 entries in order
to win this competition so it was highly
contested it's not it's not just like a
pass-through easy challenge right and
the data look kind of like this so about
1.5 million rows of offer examples like
this with some rich input features right
so you've got the name there are
categorical values lists of categories
item descriptions and some of these are
really like this is dirty data right
you've got no description yet what does
the model supposed to do with that
you've got things like redacted values
over here right this is and there were
missing values as well this is a good
real-life data set and the goal is to
break to predict the price on this
column now here what you see is a curve
where we laid out the performance of
each participant in terms of the final
error achieved so the further you are to
the right the better that participant
did on the final leaderboard right and
the higher you are on the y-axis the the
higher the error on the final test set
so as expected there is a line that
slopes downwards to the bottom right but
importantly it isn't a consistent curve
so what you'll see here is that in the
in the beginning there's a steep decline
right
we're better feature engineering better
model selection and all that like it
really matters there's still more signal
to be squeezed out of the data but then
there's a long plateau where basically
most of the competitors have kind of
done whatever they can to squeeze the
signal out of the data already so
getting to the top 25% actually gets you
to that photo right and here is how auto
melt tables does after different numbers
of hours of training so the way tables
works is you select the number of hours
and here we have tables after one hour
of training twelve hours of training and
24 hours of training so caveats right
the architecture search the hyper
parameter tuning process these are all
random so if you if you run this
yourself it might be a little bit more a
little bit less and we did do some
limited data cleaning so for example
previously the categories were split by
slashes so our system just treated as
one big token so in order to treat it as
individual words you actually have to
break up break out the slashes by
replacing them with whitespace but this
is basic very basic stuff right and of
course this is just the Macari challenge
other challenges might have different
results but still for a million row data
set a million plus row data set with
significant complexity one hour of
training by automotives gets you here
one hour of training and oh by the way
as I mentioned earlier the competition
prize for this was a hundred thousand
dollars and in comparison one hour of
training on automail tables is going to
be 19 dollars and by the way you click
one more time well so the the winning
model this is well known for capital
competitions the winning model typically
takes months of time to deploy to
actually production eyes and deploy but
for automobiles with one more click and
you can deploy the model into production
so how's that sound is it a good deal
this brings me to my final point which
is by using automata Bowles you'll save
money not only does it increase your
team's efficiency but also there is no
large annual licensing fee you basically
P you basically pay for what you use and
how we calculate what you use is that
it's just a small margin over the cost
of the underlying compute and memory
infrastructure used so for example when
I said earlier that training costed $19
per hour that basically represents the
cost of 92 for CPU machines on Google
compute engine we're using equivalent of
that essentially under the hood and
prediction and model deployment would be
even even cheaper than that and
regarding reference customers we've had
where were thankful that we've had a
significant group of customers that
agreed to join our alpha pilot with a
number of them agreeing to be public
references listed here we're proud that
we've been able to prove our relevance
across geographies industries and
company sizes you can see there are a
wide variety of company types here and
profiles here with wide varieties of
also sophistication in terms of data
science so you'll hear specific use
cases from fox sports as well as gene P
Seguros shortly but before we get too
carried away I'll be the first to admit
that we are not perfect for everyone so
automotives is usually the best fit if
you meet the following criteria so first
of all you have to know how to create
good training data and this is this is
probably the most important point right
somebody in the room needs to know how
to take a business problem and translate
it into an ml set up a classification or
a regression problem of some sort right
binary or multi-class classification and
that person needs to be able to take
training data especially defining the
label column the target column so that
it represents the way you want the model
to perform in production and somebody
also needs to understand how to make
sure that the input features are the
same in terms of distribution are the
same as what is available at serving
time so that you can prevent training
serving skew and a trivial example of
this
if the training data was all in English
but then at serving time you were
feeding Japanese to the model obviously
it would fail second you need to be
willing to wait at least an hour so
that's our minimum unit of training is
one hour and if you're looking to do
minute by minute iteration on your model
potentially so you can move quickly
maybe it's very early in the in your
development phase then you're probably
best off using something else like
bigquery machine learning or cloud
machine learning engine and finally for
now I want to call out specifically for
now if you have a larger and more
complicated data set that that would be
ideal so right now if your data set is
more than a is less than a hundred
thousand rows you won't be fully taking
advantage of the advanced algorithms
that we're using and we're actively
working on this problem and expect more
announcements soon but for now the
bigger your data set the better and the
flip side of that is our current limit
is set at a hundred million rows just to
be conservative but if you have a data
set that goes beyond that actually we're
using Google's machine learning
infrastructure under the hood so we're
built for we're built for much bigger
than that and we would love to talk to
you if you have a data set like that so
please reach out to your Google Account
Manager and now I will go over a demo
one sec let me load this up on my
computer
ready can we can we do the demo great so
now I'll walk you through the workflow
using Auto melt tables you start by
ingesting that table of data that
represents your that represents your
problem right so it can be from bigquery
or from Google Cloud Storage so you just
select it from Google Cloud Storage you
select your table so you want to use
this one and then you ingest we've
already ingested it to save everybody
time so the next step is after you
ingest you will see a schema page like
this where you can fix the variable type
if it's set to be the wrong one we do
automatic schema inference but you can
update it if it needs to be updated
right you can also change the columns in
case they could potentially be missing
right so maybe a prediction time one of
these columns might be missing so you
can turn on that it can be nullable and
then you select the target column so for
example in this problem actually the
target column and the target is supposed
to be deposit so this specific data set
is about binary classification
predicting after marketing outreach
whether somebody will make a deposit at
this Bank or not so it's a
classification problem and the and the
target is deposit and if you're an
advanced user there are additional
parameters you can set so for example
you could set your own data split
between training evaluation and holdout
sets if certain rows are more important
than others you can set away call them
and if this data has a ordering over
time that matters then you can set a
time column and this will make sure that
the latest data shows up in the holdout
set instead of the training data inside
instead of the training split next after
you've set your schema we provide a
dashboard of basic feature statistics so
that you can detect common data issues
so for example we allow filtering by the
feature type and there are more options
available but this particular data set
just has an American categorical values
to keep it simple and you can
potentially see ok what percent of them
were missing maybe that could indicate
system problems you can see how many
distinct values
there are so four categorical values
especially if you have a cardinality the
number of distinct values that is
similar to the number of rows then that
probably means that that column adds
more noise than signal and you should
remove it and then finally you contend
it detects argot for target leakage as
well as for numeric numeric feature
types seeing the basic distribution and
also if you deep dive on any of these
particular feature columns you can see
things like the distribution of the
values the top correlated features to it
and and so forth there's what will keep
on adding more as as you asked for them
more more feature statistic displays
next after you're comfortable with your
data you can train a model so you set
your model name you set how many hours
you want to train for and usually as you
soften the Macari example one hours is a
good place to start you select which
feature columns you want to use we
automatically set an optimization
objective for you but if you want to set
an objective yourself because you know
that one of them lines up better with
your business goal you can do that right
and then you train a model
I've already trained a couple here so
let's deep dive into one of them next is
the evaluation tab just so we provide
both the overall performance of that
model here on the top as well as some
useful metadata like what features were
used and what it was set to optimize for
as well as allowing you to export the
predictions on the test set to bigquery
if you want to do additional analysis as
well as evaluation metrics on individual
label slices so here for this data set
the value 1 means that they did not make
a deposit at the bank and that's 90
percent of the data right so you'll see
that you'll be able to see that here's
the model performance for that slice of
the of the data and then 2 means that
they did make a deposit so that's the
minority class and you'll see that it
does slightly worse but that's that's
typically common for imbalanced data
sets
and it's up to you to figure out how you
want to what are that's efficient or
whether you want to try other things
like improving the weight of the
imbalance class and so forth so if you
flip between them and kind of see the
difference right you can set the score
threshold to see how the precision and
recall are at different points on that
curve if you're interested in exactly
how miss classification is happening on
the model then you can look at the
confusion matrix to see that and then we
have feature importance just to get give
you a sense of which features were the
most important for making those
predictions and finally in the predict
tab we allow batch prediction and online
prediction so with batch prediction you
can upload a table from bigquery or from
Google Cloud storage and export your
results there as well and for online
prediction it's like I said it's one
click to deploy your model we took a
ploy globally to make sure that you get
low latency serving and then you can
test your model here inside the
dashboard so let's hopefully the demo
gods are kind to me and this is working
great so you can see the prediction
result right and for regression problems
we would give you a prediction interval
a 95% confidence interval and for
classification we will provide
confidence scores for the different
labels and that concludes my demo can we
move back to the slides great and now
I'm excited to introduce Chris and Jack
to share how Fox Sports is creatively
using auto mail tables to deliver a
brilliant audience experience so all
right I'm clicker g'day my name is Chris
Pocock and first of all I'd like to say
thank you to tin young and the team at
Google for inviting us over from the
other side of the world to come and
share our story about Monte I'd also
like to introduce Jack Smyth waving over
there he'll be talking to you again in a
few minutes time so look I look after my
boxing for Fox Sports Australia and it's
kind of a privilege to be able to get
paid to talk about sport all day long so
it's a pretty cool job so I am actually
originally from the UK I've lived in
Australia for about five years so I want
to start off by giving a foreigners
context on what sport means to
Australians it's a sporting nation it's
kind of the little guys punching above
their weight it's not just part of the
life they live and breathe it it's part
of the psyche it's part of their
national identity they identify
themselves through sporting success so
sport is a really really big deal in
this country to give you a little bit of
context looking at the Greater Los
Angeles area
there's 18 million people that live
there they've got about 10 professional
sports teams by my reckoning Sydney four
and a half million people pretty big
we have 25 professional sports teams so
there's a lot of sport to go around the
other kind of contextual thing is that
Australians have kind of looked at
international sport and they've looked
football soccer from Europe and then
they've looked at American football gan
naps not for us we're just going to
invent our own sport so they've invented
Australian rules football is probably
one of the most popular games in the
country only played in Australia
professionally but it is a big big sport
for them so big they're in this little
country of about 25 million people they
pack out a stadium 90,000 people week in
week out so it's pretty impressive but
Australian balls footballs not the only
sport played Australia is actually a
pretty divided nation when it comes to
sport so I'm just kind of highlighting
up some of our key sports we have here
so we have a rugby union at the top
Australian rules football rugby league
and motorsport those are the key
broadcast sports that we have on the Fox
Sports
but within Australia itself certain
sports have bigger popularity than the
other depending on where you live or
where you went to school rugby league
for example really big in Sydney
not so much in Melbourne Australian
rules football really big in Melbourne
not so big in Sydney
so it's a divided nation so it kind of
takes us through our journey Foxsports
where we have all these key sports from
January through to September it's a
great lineup there's a bit of a gap in
the summer so last year we signed a
broadcast rights deal for cricket and
cricket is the summer sport you'll
notice that it kind of looks at October
December we're upside down that is our
summer time so that kind of filled the
gap and cricket it cost us a billion
dollars for the broadcast rights for
that so it's a little bit of importance
on making it work so we had to look at
cricket from a context of it if having
been on free-to-air television so
Australians been able to watch it for
free since day dawn we're now asking you
to pay for it so we had to promise a
cricket experience like never before and
this is kind of where our auto ml tables
came in now I'm conscious of where I'm
standing and what country I'm in so just
want to talk a little bit about what
cricket actually is it's a game that we
sometimes play for five days and no one
wins so the kind of thing that blows a
few minds in Australia we draw quite a
lot but it can be like a chess match it
so it's really really tactical and what
you'll see is kind of the last man
holding on against big Goliath fast
bowlers or the game changing on a dime
with three quick wickets is it does
explode into action but realistically
there are only 18 seconds of wickets so
the wicket being this guy here the aim
of the game is for this guy to bowl this
guy out that really gives us across five
days 18 seconds of action it's a long
long game so what we try and do with
this experiment with the automail tables
is to warn fans when we think a wicket
is going to happen ahead of time so they
know that they need to be in front of
the screen don't go to the bathroom
don't go out and do a barbecue because
because the action is coming up now
cricket also is a really great game for
structured data there's a lot of
different variables that we can measure
to accurately predict what we think is
going to happen in a few
that types of ball balled you spin you
can do fast how long is the batsman
there being at the crease has he been
there for an hour has he been there for
four hours is he tired not tired as he
run around a lot
is he the last man standing generally
the last man standing is a lesser
batsman versus the first guy who goes
out what field positions as the captain
set out around where they looking to
catch the ball and about 80 other data
points Oh makes it an ideal experiment
that we tried out last summer and it
bloody worked which was quite impressive
so look mmm I want to let Monty
so just a little bit of context we named
him Monty because the first wicket he
accurately predicted was a chap called
Monty Panesar so it seemed apt to name
him after that so I am going to
introduce you to this is a world first a
world's first automated machine learning
commentator I'll let Monty give it to
you in his own words
[Music]
[Applause]
some beauty
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
absolutely brilliant
okay all right thanks so much Chris over
on my name's Jack oh I'll wait for
applause ah my name is Jack and I'll
walk you through how mine share created
Monty in collaboration with Google now
the first step is a final world-class
data provider in Optus sports so they
attract eighty-three unique variables
with every single ball and that's
available within seconds of it leaving
the bowlers hand so we knew we had great
training data and a live feed set up so
after that we could start experimenting
with tables now say the first
impressions of tables were striking the
speed and simplicity of this platform
blew us away we could easily ingest a
year's worth of training data simply
select wickets as a label to predict and
within hours we were seeing impressive
results to be totally honest some of the
team members even thought that Monty
must be cheating because the earlier
results was simply that good however
those doubts quickly evaporated as we
move through the training process tables
allowed us to collaborate a model that
could keep pace with a live game so we
moved ahead with the classification
model so we could not only predict when
or wicker would fall but how and the
final output looks something like this
this is a real example from a recent
game between England and the West Indies
and you can see the endpoint would
return an analysis of the latest ball
and in this case the batsman safe for
the next five minutes the prediction is
not out but then you can see the
confidence scores for each method of
taking a wicket and there's a rising
danger there of him being caught so once
we saw the accuracy during testing
we knew the monty was ready for the main
stage and I have to say as Australians
we don't really believe in soft launches
so we chose the biggest most iconic
match in the Australian sporting
calendar to debut Monty now millions of
fans of the MCG
we come here every boxing day for
Australia's biggest day of cricket day
one of the Melbourne Test match more
than 80,000 fans in the stands millions
watching and listening around the world
magically drawn to the history and the
tradition
this is where reputations are made this
is where Dennis Lillee knocks over fever
idiots with the last fall of the day you
don't forget that as a kid you dream of
doing something amazing at the g and a
few get lucky right so how did it go
Monty absolutely that was seamless so
how did he go
Monty absolutely smashed expectations in
his first game we were thrilled with the
accuracy and tables really came through
when it counted most when we have most
of the country counting on Monty's call
so he's confident scores for each wicket
were displayed live in ads just like
this for millions of fans and that
stretched from push notifications the
Fox Creek adapt all the way through to
pre-roll and we were thrilled
without accuracy figure that is
astonishing for live sport and I would
say as well that even the moments he
missed became highlights in their own
right because that meant that a bowler
had come out of nowhere to take a wicket
without warning they'd literally beaten
the odds now as our confidence grew in
Monty we use then essentially scaled him
up to become the command center of our
entire campaign so this is the final
architecture and this is largely thanks
to an amazing Googler back in Sydney
named drew Jarrett and in the time
remaining I'll give you a quick overview
of how it worked down here when a ball
was a pass through our system from
ophtho App Engine would receive that it
would pass it through for processing
we'd use data flow to look at that ball
and also an aggregate of the recent
balls to give us what we called a
prediction window the model would then
make a prediction based on that window
and the individual ball and then App
Engine would facilitate requests from
live digital billboards from the Fox
Creek adapt Google ads bidding scripts
studio dynamic templates and even Google
assistant and I have to say for me the
Google assistant experience was a
particular highlight this was combining
the predictive power of auto ml tables
with the personalization capabilities of
assistant
we could genuinely offer every fan their
very own on-demand commentator so
through cistern fans could ask for the
latest call from Monty they could
understand how he had made that
prediction and of course they get the
latest team news and for me this is more
than marketing this is an entirely new
product experience made possible through
tables and it's one that we are very
very proud of and the close of the
campaign the impact of tables was clear
so we saw a hundred and fifty percent
improvement in marketing ROI brand
recall for Fox Sports doubled and the
Fox Creek adapt delivered an increase of
a hundred and forty percent compared to
category competitors so the scorecard
like that you can be certain you haven't
heard last Monty and I'll hand you back
to Chris he'll be able to talk you
through where we're going next thanks
jack
so those are pretty damn good results
and it frankly took me by surprise just
how well it all worked so this is not
the end of our journey what we really
want to do is take Monte forward and
beyond what we've done this last summer
not only taking it into our next summer
but also start applying it to some of
our winter sports so we're looking at
doing a man versus machine let Monte
take on our soar panel of experts what
do they think the results are going to
be can they beat Auto ml really excited
to see if they can all con we also want
to be able to integrate it properly on
our air so on our broadcast being able
to allow our commentators to warn fans
when exciting moments are upcoming don't
go to the bathroom make sure you stick
around
Monte thinks there's a wicket coming
fantasy is also a fantastic way of
applying Monty's learning model each
week he'll build his ultimate team and
can it be all of our consumers all of
our experts week in week out by building
based on structured data versus the gut
feel of our experts let's see what
happens I'm really excited for the
future it's been an amazing products a
great journey so thank you to everyone
and appreciate you listening to our
story
so now just my last roll of the day is
to introduce Enrique and Carlos from GMP
Seguros hopefully I pronounced that
properly but I'm welcome guys and thank
you thank you very much
well hello thank you to Dean Yan and to
Google for inviting us to share our
experience with Auto ml at this
conference and congratulations to fox
for such so such an interesting case GNP
is one of the largest insurance
companies in Mexico the company was
founded a hundred and sixteen years ago
and we have yearly sales of around three
billion dollars as any large and
well-established company GMP is
undergoing a profound transformation I
was going to say a digital digital
transformation we haven't quite figure
out the precise definition of digital
transformation because everyone's
talking about it so I'll just mention
transformation but anyway what we want
to do is to modernize our information
systems and our operations and we're
leveraging heavily on the cloud to
achieve that and one of the strategic
initiatives that we're executing under
this transformation is to assemble a
single corporate data link that is a
single repository where all the
information of the company will reside
and besides being an important enabler
of efficiency because we don't have to
figure out where to go and look for
information because everything is going
to be located or is located already in
the central data Lake we regard the data
lake as an important source of
competitive differentiation and of us
enough intelligence and to achieve that
we need to squeeze knowledge and value
from all the data that's stored in the
data Lake and to achieve that we have
recently started to use machine learning
to actually you know uncover and squeeze
the value from from the information and
the problem with machine learning is
that you know
the availability of well-trained data
scientists is not that great so you know
Carlos is a head of machine learning in
a GMP but he's kind of a rare breed of
persons because you know you don't have
that many in the market so when Google
offer us the the describe to was the
concept of Auto ml tables and they offer
us the opportunity to test it and we
thought it was absolutely great because
we want to democratize the use of
machine learning in the company lower
the complexity of generating new models
so it looked very promising and what you
know we embarked on on testing and
trying this you know this great new tool
so we basically what we did is we play
with the tool with three different use
cases one in the auto industry in the
old Insurance line of business one and
the health care and the health care line
of business and the third was general
utility for our underwriters for
underwriters for you know collective
insurances that will describe a little
later so the first example is it's
really simple it's given the
characteristics of the insured car none
of the owner try to predict what's the
probability of that car of having an
accident and to provide the highlights
of this you know the technical
highlights of this exercise I'll allow
catalyst to to share it with you again
hello to everyone
I will only explain how our using our
email tables to solve insurance problems
at a GNP as Erica said the first problem
is car claim risk this problem consists
in determining and predicting the
probability of a car accident
using drivers characteristics such as
age gender claim history as well as
vehicle characteristics such as type
model and intensity usage when one thing
that is really amazing about our models
is that you don't have to worry about
future engineering or hyper parameter
tuning development issues the only thing
that you need to do is they want the
made in 10 unit and the demo and I want
to highlight that
this had a very good quality confirmed
by the F score in the green square and I
relate the the next the to the next
problem
Enrique introduced so the second use
case that we used to try out on mail
tables is we had previously already
developed a machine learning model to
try to detect fraudulent claims in
health care and what we did is you know
we created a new model using our 2 ml
tables and we compared the results to
the results are already provided by the
existing model that we have and given
the characteristics of you know of the
patient which is our customer and the
sales agent who saw the policy to this
customer and the specific disease that
this person has and the hospital and the
doctors involved we try to to determine
if that claim is fraudulent or not just
to give you an idea you know our yearly
expense on healthcare claims he's around
six hundred and eighty million dollars
so any small percentage that we can
achieve in improving the you know
detecting fraudulent claims it
translates directly into a lot of
additional revenue to the company so I
liked Carlos you know provide you with
the highlights of this exercise okay
thanks Erika again we use like claim kay
the clients claim history as well as
medical hospitals information and one
thing that is really neat about the
outer Mel's tables is that you have all
the performance revelations or the
performance results that you need at a
click distance you don't have to make
additional work in you know in order to
compute evaluation matrix and I want to
highlight that this model had like a
very high quality compared by the f1
score of 0.94 and we we confirmed this
quality on an independent holdout set
and and I want to highlight that it had
led twenty to thirty percent improvement
respect to our existing ml solutions so
bottom line we were really impressed
just by using auto ml we got
twenty percent between twenty and thirty
percent increase in in in in in
effectiveness of the Tecton claim so
that was really promising and I'm very
encouraging to continue using this this
tool and the last example was a
practical example you know we not only
ensure individuals we also ensure
collectives of people that is for
example all the employees of a company
so let's say that we're going to ensure
all the you know all the employees of a
specific company so what usually the
sales channel does is once that they do
the sale they provide either a CSB or a
spreadsheet file to our underwriting
department so they can do the quote and
the underwriting of the policy and one
of the fields that is required for each
of the persons that integrate you know
this collective of people is the gender
of the person but sometimes you know the
sales channel omits to provide that
information and what that happens you
know the underwriting department they
need what they usually did before was
break up the file into you know many
small different files and then send that
file to a lot of different persons and
manually each person will basically
classify even based on the name of the
person who that person is male or female
so you know the last time that that
happened one of the last times that that
happened the file was 10,000 rows long
so it was a lot of work so you know one
of the persons from the underwriting
Department approached our data science
team and said well you're supposed to be
smart and there should be a better way
of doing this and it was a simple
example what we did is basically we used
our master database as you know as a
data of the master database to train a
model to learn what's the gender of a
person based on its name and last name
since its full name so that's basically
what we did and and that was a it was it
says it's a small problem to solve but
it's actually it had a lot of practical
usage in the company because that this
kind of happens kind of often so it
ended up being a usable tool and
let catalysis describe justice this
exercise thanks again
well as you can see in the screen we we
made a comparison between a is naive
model only using the future column of
the first name and obviously we got a
bad quality result and we made a little
character level feature engineering and
we decompose the first name into
suffixes and prefixes and we gain a lot
of performance as can be seen screen
this this shows the power at hand that
that makes our email tables when when
the Rivard irrelevant variables are are
chosen and again I want to thank the the
Google cloud team for letting so in this
example by tweaking a little bit the
feature engineering we were able to and
leveraging on on auto ml tables we were
able to achieve a very high efficiency
of this model so this is just another
small example of how can we use this
tool and the results that we saw in auto
ml with you know with the use cases that
we develop a GMP are really promising so
we're really excited on in the idea of
leveraging on this tool to developing
more machine learning models much more
quickly
you know we're determined to use machine
learning to solve real business problems
or problems are already solved with some
sort of automation giving them a much
better solution and one way to achieve
this results quicker is through tools
like machine learning and one of the
things that we want to achieve is
currently the underwriting of medical
healthcare goes through a process and
you know using a set of predefined rules
around fifty five percent of all the new
customers you know it's on the writing
process is fully automatic and we want
to change the implementation that we
have we want to replace the static rules
with a machine learning model that would
allow us to have 80% of all the of all
the underwriting instances to be fully
automatic
only a 20% will be derived to a set of
experts to the term in the unit the
underwriting so that's one of the
targets that we have and on the other
end since we already compare the results
that we got with Auto ml with the
existing machine learning model we have
for detecting frontal and healthcare
claims we want to improve in ten percent
this year the the amount of of claim of
fraud and claims that we're able to
detect in order to contribute to
additional revenue in the company so
that's basically what we've done a GMP I
think this is a it's a great tool and
back to you Dean you thanks
[Music]